I can see your sweat and the tears in
your eyes everything shows you want to
give up and I can feel your pain and to
start using my music to speak about the
injustices and oppression of other
people but also we sing about our
imagination the envisionment of a new
Uganda a free Uganda and a new and free
wife and that is Bobby he's like you
know what it's bad but it's to be okay
one day everything is going to be fine
everything's going to be fine one day
everything will be all
[Music]
right we came up with that
song towards the end of the film I
noticed that there's need to encourage
people and to encourage
[Music]
ourselves I sang that song to everybody
out there that's being oppressed remind
reming them that one day everything's
going to be all right one day everything
is going to be
[Music]
fine thank
you thank you
[Music]
yes